i have to start with a little bit of a
confession
this channel has been extremely or
recently become extremely popular among
those who are interested in the
phenomenon of ufos
but it's not a ufo channel per se it's a
channel oriented toward
the foundational aspects of our universe
and investigating it from the vantage
point of
philosophy psychology mathematics and
even theoretical physics
luckily i spoke to a few of the
ufologists who recently subscribed to
the channel
and they reassured me that people who
are interested in ufos tend to be
open-minded and interested in the topics
of theoretical physics and philosophy
anyway this quelled my initial
trepidation
but i wanted to bring it up regardless
because if what you're expecting
is mere ufo content i don't want you to
be disappointed while i'm not a
mathematician nor a physicist
i was trained as such and that's where i
tend to be most comfortable but
unlike most of the scientific community
the topics of free will
god ufos the paranormal in general
aren't topics that is chew but instead i
revel in
if one is to make progress toward a
theory of everything my bet is that
innovation will come from the fringes
what you're about to watch is a
conversation between
jacques valet a computer scientist
venture capitalist and ufologist one of
the most
credible the link is below and professor
kevin knuth is a computational physicist
as well as the editor-in-chief of
entropy journal he's also one of the few
physicists
working physicists in academia who
publish regarding the veritality
of the ufo phenomenon to use a fun word
i'm an abc darian and that has its
advantages as well as disadvantages
now the disadvantage is obviously that
i'll be asking questions
generally that are sophomoric and
unfledged such as
how does the freedom of information act
work and why do aliens
look like us or us like them at least
broadly morphologically and there were
some criticisms
rightly so of my interview with jeremy
corbell of me
not knowing much about the topic and
that's true however one of the large
advantages is that
a question that seems obvious is no
longer one that occurs to the seasoned
individual and thus a fresh perspective
can be gotten to by asking it another
advantage a meta advantage is that you
get to watch someone who's
classically trained as a mathematical
physicist
go through a constitutional change in
world view in real time
a regular theo locution on this channel
is about getting two individuals with
contrary viewpoints to hash it out
in a manner that's not dislogistic but
instead constructive and even
loving someone said it's not a live
stream it's a love stream and that's
true
however in this case both professor
kevin knuth and jacques valet
agree on far more than they disagree the
sponsor of today's podcast is
algo algo is an end-to-end supply chain
optimization software company
with software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations
planning to avoid stockouts reduce
returns and inventory write downs
while reducing inventory investment it's
a supply chain ai
that drives smart ioi headed by a bright
individual by the name of amjad hussein
amjad in fact contributed some of the
questions to today's theo locution
and he's been a huge supporter of the
podcast since nearly its inception
in fact the reason i'm standing right
now is because i was able to afford
a standing desk based purely on amjad's
contribution to this channel to help
engender a work environment where i can
just
simply focus on work and not the
extraneous aspects like
my back hurting for example another
supporter of the podcast is brilliant
you can subscribe to brilliant.org toe
t-o-e
if you'd like twenty percent off their
annual subscription and i'll be speaking
more on that
later if you'd like to hear more
conversations like this then please do
consider supporting
at patreon.com i've also recently opened
up a crypto account and a paypal account
and if you like
you can donate there i plan on having
many more conversations like this
at the end of august there's going to be
yoshibak and donald hoffman coming up
at the end of this month i'm speaking to
chris langan he's the person who has
reportedly the highest iq in america and
has a theory of everything called the
cognitive theoretic model of the
universe
there's also a discord with the link in
the description
if you'd like to discuss the topics in
this podcast or other podcast in real
time
to chat with other people who are like
yourself thank you so much
and enjoy hello how's it going
very good how are you good good to see
you
good to see you we did it i look forward
to this
say hello to the audience hey good
morning or
good afternoon wherever you are thank
you for the
invitation i gave a
tedx uh talk uh a few years ago
about uh theories of uh
everything else um
because theories of everything that's
not big enough you know you
you really have to look at the at the
boundaries
and and so what i'll be talking about
here is
maybe not everything else but something
else
that sure you know came came out of the
sky
so why don't you talk about your new
book if you can give a synopsis of it
within
four minutes yes um the
the book is called uh trinity
um the best kept secret
and it's about a case of uh
the recovery of an object that was never
identified
by the army and the army air force this
was before the
air force existed in august 1945
within days of the capitulation of japan
and it's hard to imagine that
that particular event wasn't in some way
linked to the end of world war ii and
to the first atomic bomb and to the
emergence of
our civilization into
essentially the nuclear age
what happened is that simply two
uh two boys were working in a field
for their father uh on a large property
in new mexico
within 20 miles of ground zero and
they saw something fall
so this is an exceptional case because
the witnesses were there
before the object happened this is not
like roswell where
you know debris was found a few days
later they were there
they saw it happen we have corroborating
evidence from a pilot
that was going in for landing at
alamogordo
and saw the whole thing the object was
essentially an egg-shaped uh object it
was not a flying saucer
like people described it was egg shaped
and the the two witnesses
uh one of whom is still alive uh very
much alive and
part of our investigation um
were there on the spot for the next
eight days
while the military were recovering
that object and taking it away
so it's an exceptional story that gives
us
an opportunity to do some at least some
good physics
and and to tie together all the
parameters of the of the testimony of
the evidence
what do you mean when you say gives you
the opportunity to do good physics
the uh the the object was intact
when it blended it it crash landed
but under control which is it
it didn't blow up like an airplane would
have
it hit a communication tower which was
one of
three communication towers around white
the white the whole white sands
area the area is still technically
within the military confines of white
sands which
as you know is is as large as two
american states it's a very very large
uh
test area for the military
this was again three weeks after the
explosion of the first a bomb
and um the
three people actually entered into
the craft while it was lying there
so we have testimony not only of people
who
saw it the the traces uh the
some of the data that was recovered from
inside the object
but we also have day by day
accounts which is in in in the book of
what happened what the military had to
do to recover it
so we have a good approximation of the
weight the volume
the size of the thing and we can compare
it to
other cases in the literature that have
been studied by
um officially by the air force the
french air force or the american air
force
at other places so again i come into
this as an
information scientist not not as a
physicist although
i am a lapsed astrophysicist you know
from my days
at the university of texas and at
northwestern but
my most of my contribution here
is as part of a team of people looking
looking at the information structures
among a number of cases like that
what is its weight and volume compared
to others and also when you say
physics do you mean to say material
engineering or physics as in theoretical
physics
um well it the theoretical physics part
is
left to to the student you know
uh to to develop um we don't know
where it comes from uh it was not
tracked
as far as we know by any radar as it was
coming in according to
mr jose padilla who's our main witness
today
uh it he believes that it came from
the south which would have been the
direction of of the test site
where the atomic explosion had taken
place
um it um it seems
that you know given the traces i mean
the the thing after hitting the tower
the thing fell
hit the ground starting a fire in the
vegetation if you know new mexico
uh we're at 5000 feet altitude
and the vegetation is mostly crazy and
cactus and that kind of thing it burned
the object did not burn the object kept
its um
its identity and uh actually
plowed a path down
down the prairie down down that field
made a turn
apparently under power and and stopped
against a
hill so uh that gives us an idea
we reconstructed the weight only
approximately
that it certainly could not be moved by
by men
uh they had to build a crane and we know
everything that the military did because
witnesses were there
all the time in successive days
they had to actually uh bring
an 18-wheeler a low boy you know
army truck and build a crane to lift the
object so
the the weight would be in the area of
about five turns
you know five or seven tons i recall you
talking about the outside material being
extremely
light the
it it some of the
in in the impact against the tower there
was material that was ejected there was
one panel
from the object that was destroyed
and that material was recovered by the
kids later on
um there were actually four types
of material that the witnesses described
that uh you know we we hope eventually
to
maybe recover from some of the people in
the area if they kept some of it as a
as a souvenir but remember it's 80 years
ago
and the reason the book is called the
best kept secret
is that it's not in the air force files
as you may know as part of my my work on
the subject
i've built various databases of the air
force fires both here
and in france and elsewhere uh it
doesn't show up anywhere
so that that secret was kept very very
well
within the atomic fives
not within the air force fives or the
army fights
where we would have found it i mean as
you know i worked with dr heineck who
was
for 25 years a consultant to the u.s air
force
we never heard of that case the other
reason we never heard of it is that the
witnesses
never came forward which is
astonishing until you recall the
conditions in 1945 and after the war
we went from a shooting wall to the cold
war
there was intense secrecy and
classification on
everything going on in new mexico you
know from los alamos to alamogordo and
everything else and the
the young men as they grew up decided
they would never
talk about it uh also some of the things
i had recovered
were could have been very controversial
they they are controversial today and
there's there is some physical evidence
in connection with
that recovery is it all right if i admit
kevin knows now
it's your show the more the merrier
hello sorry for being late that's all
right thank you so much for coming i
know that
you're under a bit of stress right now
that's all right thank you
okay jack do you mind recapitulating
what you said
in about a minute just for kevin knows
to bring him up so
this case is uh unique i'm uh
i've gone there five times i'm working
with paola harris
who actually initiated the research on
this
when she uh interviewed the the two
main witnesses we actually have four
four different witnesses to the case
that our
first hand where we have first-hand
testimony
the case is unique in the analyst
because it has to do
with the crash of an object in new
mexico
two days after the capitulation of japan
in an area that was a military area
part of the manhattan project complex
around white sands the the two witnesses
were there
at the time when the object came down
from the sky
halo tower was partially damaged and
then made a crash landing under power
they had the opportunity to to examine
the object when it was sitting there
in in that on on that property which was
their
their father's property and uh
three people including two adults
uh including a state officer
uh actually went inside the object so we
have testimony from both outside and
inside
and the two young men were there for
eight days afterwards
and observed the entire
process of recovery of the object which
was taken away
on an 18-wheeler back to white sands by
the army
so we have an extraordinary amount of
information
just on that one case now again
i'm i have to repeat again i am
i'm not a theoretical physicist here i'm
i'm
mainly an information scientist with a
background in physics
and so i've tried to relate
that particular case with a pattern of
other cases in the literature
that have been studied by government
agencies both in the u.s and in france
and enable us to come up with
at least some parameters of what the
problem is
so kevin the way i would like this to be
would be more of a conversation between
both of you and i
am just an observer or fly on the wall
so what thoughts occur to you
or questions occur to you when you hear
that
directed to jack right
well thank you thank you very much for
having me join you
jacques it's good to see you again and
and um
and i read about this case briefly so
i'm really excited to hear it about it
from you
um let's see here i
well a question that occurs to me is
jacques do you have any ideas as to why
they're falling from the sky
because the skeptic would say if they're
so advanced then why are they
not necessarily crashing but hitting
some of these earthly objects when
our planes don't necessarily do that at
least now there are a lot of crashes
that's always where there's a lot of
reported crashes that's always worrying
me a bit
yes and uh and i must admit uh
in in the book i you know i make it
clear that i i have not been
very involved in the study of crashes
because
i remember discussing roswell with dr
heineck and and
with uh professor mcdonald and with
other people
and with people at the at the air force
when uh
you know i was i consulted briefly for
project blue book at
wright patterson um they
they had you know material that
witnesses had
brought to the air force to project blue
book in those days
saying you know this crashed on my
property and so on
but we we had we never could get to
real evidence from primary witnesses
if you remember roswell of course is
you know a very prominent case uh
it happened uh the testimony is more and
more clear as
people are reconstructing the history of
it but there was nobody
on site when it happened people
you know came up came upon the wreckage
later the they reconstructed
a number of investigators including
stanton friedman
others have reconstructed what the air
force did
but there wasn't a case where there was
really evidence that we could
we could touch and we could hear from
live witnesses who had been there while
it happened
in this case we do and that's why you
know i
i devoted time to that i went to the
site several times
uh i had a chance to interview the
people there and to
to reconstruct the history of it because
it's
and then we can put it in the context of
other crazy cases that were not crashes
but were hard landings that
are in the official government files
of france and of the us namely the
socorro case
which took place just eight miles north
of there and the case in valencia in
france
in provence which i've investigated also
i've gone there
with french government officials and
that case is still unidentified uh
in their files and socorro as you may
know is still
unidentified in the air force files
after long investigations by
by a number of agencies including the
air force including the fbi
including uh project blue book and
including the local police of course and
the state police of new mexico
so we have all of that and all of that
is in the book so
again i'm i'm think of me as an
information scientist
with a servant to you know the
the physicists and the the biologists
who are going to look into this
and uh i'm trying to bring you a a
pattern
that makes sense you mentioned patterns
is there a pattern or a correlation
between some of the
hot spots of ufo locations that you
discovered
the the the pattern i i want to mention
is
you know on this page of of the book
he knows three cases namely the new
mexico case
socorro and valencia in france
we know pretty much everything about the
object um
at least the size and the weight because
there were
hard traces in the ground that could be
measured could were preserved
at the site in minutes after the case
happened
and in all three cases it's not a saucer
it's not
a disk it's not a flying saucer it's an
egg shaped object
the witnesses in new mexico called it an
avocado
so there was there was you know the
typical shape of an avocado so it wasn't
a perfect oval
in socorro it was somewhat smaller but
again we have a very precise description
by
uh lonnie zamora who's a patrolman who
saw the object arrive and in
valencia we have the main witness uh mr
maurice mas whom i've interviewed
the object was about 13 feet
and again it was an egg-shaped object
with
some sort of dome on top so those are
three
very similar cases in all three cases
the witnesses described occupants
presumably the pilots of craft
as being about three to four feet tall
breathing our air breathing
breathing our air yes they
they were breathing normally they didn't
have any
you know any helmet they didn't have any
anything around their heads
um they had um
[Music]
apparently a suit covering their body
that
was close tied to the skin
and in one case i couldn't tell if it
was the skin
or if it was actually the suit
there were no anatomically very similar
to
humans all human they had two eyes and
a mouth and a nose the nose was smaller
but essentially the witnesses could
relate to them
as
close enough to us that they thought of
them
as human and are humanoid
although in the new mexico case
there was there was more there was a
like a communication and i i know your
group is interested in consciousness
there's a lot between the lines about
the uh all the feelings all the
psychological impact that these two kids
remember the witnesses were a
nine-year-old and a seven-year-old
but remember this was
at the end of world war ii i mean the
nine-year-old was driving the truck
they had binoculars to read
the markings on the brands on the
the cattle for their father they they
were taking care of the herd
uh on on this uh property which was 80
000
acres so these were kids in very special
conditions they knew the territory very
well
they had horses to go over this this
terrain
they knew how to hide when they were
watching the
soldiers recovering this object and
loading it
on the on the truck so they are able to
give us very very good testimony one of
them
has passed away a few years ago but my
co-author
paula harris was involved in the case
five years before me and she had
interviewed him
she actually is the first one to have
recovered
to have uh recovered the whole interview
from both of them
even you know before i got involved in
the case
i got involved of the correlation
the historical correlation with the atom
bomb
and which
again we we have to ask
why would and that's implicit in
what kevin was saying i mean why would
you come from
alpha centauri and would why would you
hit a tower
you know and crash i mean that doesn't
make any sense
well we don't know if they came from
from alpha centauri
we don't know where they came from they
they didn't necessarily drop from the
sky
they flew over as far as the witnesses
could tell they they flew over
uh this landscape apparently coming from
the project manhattan you know a test
site
they hit the tower
they crash landed under power
and then came to rest in this landscape
setting the bushes on fire
so when the witnesses arrive they you
know their eyes are tearing up
they they don't they they think
remember the the expression flying
saucer
is not in the english language at this
point this is the end of world war
ii so the their first reaction is
something crashed we have to help you
know
you know the first witness is on the
site they knew that
they had to get help for the pilots or
whoever had crashed
they they didn't know what it was they
assume it's some sort
of airplane or some sort of prototype
and they are going to go there and help
whoever may be wounded
at the site that's a motivation the term
flying saucer doesn't exist
roswell is two years away in the future
kenneth arnold has not done his report
there isn't even an air force i mean
there is an army air force which is part
of the army
there is a pilot named bravi
whose testimony we have who was coming
in for a landing at alamogordo
he sees the smoke contacts the tower
the tower tells him to look
at the control tower tells him to look
at the communication tower because
they've lost
communication with it he flies
over the uh you know
what they called in those days with
fermi
tower uh the and they
um they observe the the damage to the
tower
and then he sees the the fire
and he sees two little kids next to it
he calls indian kids they're not indian
uh they are mexican and
apparently spanish origin but they
they are not they are not technically
indians but they are on their horses and
they are
there at the site and the pilot
describes them
and we believe the pilot is the one who
came back the next day
to retrieve some of the data on the site
the next day is the only day when the
two kids were not back
on site because they were working for
their father
in town after that they were on site
every day during the entire recovery
so that's the overall scene
that's why i became involved because i
mean the story was
complete i mean we had the witnesses we
had the testimony with the traces
and we had testimony from two adults and
one child
who actually went inside
kevin i'm not sure if you can hear me
but if you can you look like you were
thinking
and i'm curious to know what's going
through your head you can direct it to
jacques
yeah no i i'm sorry i didn't know about
the um
the pilot being a witness and i think
that's excellent that
that um that you were able to get
his testimony as well and and that he
can confirm that the
the two boys were there that's really
fascinating
um and yeah so this is
1945. is that correct it would have been
1945 everybody is still in uniform
uh the army has not been demobilized
they are about to be
um japan has just capitulated two days
before
right so all right
yeah and i'm thinking about all the
there were
there was a lot of ufo activity around
white sands missile base
you know during the during the manhattan
project as well if i remember right
there there were there were sightings
there i mean what do you know about that
i mean i don't know i don't know much
about that so uh that's a good question
um
if you look at the air force fines of
project blue book that went back into
into you know history this case is not
mentioned anywhere
that just doesn't exist it was never
reported
uh to project blue book um
and we that's an interesting question of
about why
why it wasn't and why nobody knew about
it for
essentially you know almost 80 years
the they were of course around the
manhattan project
there were a number of radars including
long-range radars
and uh wherever you have radar you'll
have
you know things that are reported by the
radar people
that as unusual things and usually you
you send you send an aircraft to verify
what it is so
uh yes there were reports
certainly there were many reports around
new mexico around that time
but to me uh there was nothing like this
you know it's only after 1947
you know kenneth arnold talks about what
he saw
a very very credible pilot uh that
creates the term flying saucer the press
the american
newspapers get all excited about it
the air force starts its investigation
uh and and then of course there is
the roswell crash so around that time
people start reporting everything
they've seen
but for uh in the air force fives
that i have a complete record of the
original files there are only four
cases reported in 1945
around that time including one
remarkably from
a citizen in uh el paso who actually saw
the atom bomb
he saw the the test of the the first a
bomb
saw the mushroom cloud and reported it
as something in the sky that
he couldn't understand that they had
never seen before
which is remarkable so yes there was a
lot of scrutiny of the sky
uh just because they had to be aware of
spying or anything you know
going over uh the the test side
um just because there could be accidents
if
if some civilian pilot went over the
military
test side but there was nothing like
like this so again we don't know where
it came from
uh mr padilla told me that he
thought and and his his argument is
i mean he didn't see it coming um he saw
the crash
but he didn't see it coming when it hit
the tower
but again you're dealing with very
clever kids who were
entrusted with you know guarding the
cattle
and the property fixing the fences and
all the
shores on the farm and so
this nine-year-old after a few days
decided to climb the tower
you know the marconi tower that had been
hit he climbed about halfway up
the this about 70 foot high
tower to look at
where the impact had been i mean there
was one leg of that tower
and you could i've been there you can
still see where the legs were
well it must have been a very large
tower and it was there because
in the north the the landscape goes up
to a cliff
and uh airplanes had been hitting that
cliff so
it was there to preserve to warm pilots
remember you're at 5000 feet at
you know there and then the cliff goes
up from there and so that
tower was there to protect the northern
area of the manhattan project
and the uh so this kid goes up the
the tower and he watches where the leg
is bent
and that tells him what direction the
object came from
again those were clever kids i mean they
you know
you learned quickly in those days you
know now i
i grew up in france in occupied france
okay uh i was born 1939 so
you know i'm in age i'm close to
those those witnesses uh i
you know i was old enough at the end of
the war
to understand to be able to place myself
in
in similar conditions uh watching
you know the liberation of france what
people were doing around that day and
those days and what was secret the
things you couldn't talk about the
things that
even as a kid i mean this was it was
clear
you know about how you had to behave and
uh
remember the nine-year-old was driving
the family truck i mean there was
everybody else was in uniform or was too
old to drive the truck
jack you mentioned that there is an
aspect of consciousness associated with
this event
do you mind explaining what you mean it
comes up again and again and again
and remember i worked initially from the
transcripts
of the interviews that paola harris had
done
very very well she's a very good
you know investigator and trained
journalist
she recorded all those conversations
with both mr padilla
and mr baka remy bakker who
by then was an entrepreneur in
washington state
um in in the interviews
i i was trying to reconstruct going word
by word reconstructing
the scene and they say well they were
there for
maybe 15 20 minutes and then in
when you put the testimony together they
were there for like an hour and a half
well i don't know if you have kids but
my kids
when they were seven or nine you
couldn't make them stand still for an
hour and a half
to let alone 20 minutes uh what were
they doing
so i've had the privilege of
reinterviewing
mr padilla about this and he said well
they were
wanted to go and help they are there
the there is an opening in the object
through there they see three beings who
are about their size
they think of them as little men or
kids although
they also look a little bit like a large
insect
they they are not completely human they
have a large head
shoulders long arms
and they they walk not by walking but by
just moving around shuffling willing
themselves to move around
you happen to have a picture of it in
your book uh
no no well i have pictures
of um i have pictures of
you know what you could compare it to
but
they um
they were they felt mr paliya told me we
felt sorry for them
he wanted to go and help and he said you
know
if i had done that i probably wouldn't
be here talking to you
uh you know going into that craft they
were always
inside sort of moving back and forth
crying and crying yes and he compared it
to
the cry of a rabbit when you kill it
again these kids are growing up on the
on the ranch okay
they are very familiar with animals with
you know
preparing food and everything else they
they are
sort of crying they are in distress
and they are moving around he wants to
go and help
the seven-year-old says no way i'm not
going there
he's crying he's really terrified
he doesn't want to get involved they are
200 feet away from the object at that
point
okay this is their land i mean they know
the territory they but they see this
thing there is no more smoke no more
fire
the the object was never on fire by the
way the object is intact
which is kind of remarkable after what
it went through
the only thing missing is that panel a
lot of
material that they talk about light
material
a lot of that light silvery material
that they will compare to
uh they will compare to
a fiber optic they will compare it to
things you put on the christmas tree
silver you know
silver material very light
light aluminum
and just shiny stuff in fact
some of the fiber they they recovered
they filled
a big sack with it and they gave it to
their neighbors to put on their
christmas trees
i mean again this was
what a kid would do i mean they they
recovered it they thought it was
wonderful it was mysterious they didn't
have many toys in those days you know
where does consciousness enter into this
so the consciousness is that they
they feel that the beings are
communicating with them
so the beings were aware that sorry to
interrupt the beings were aware that
they were there 200 feet away or did
they come closer
they that we asked that question
the the the beings were not looking
directly at them
but they they felt that the beings were
uh aware that they were there
they remember they had binoculars so
they passed
the binoculars to each other staring at
these
and these creatures and uh
feeling sorry for them feeling pain
feeling that they should help
and they were helpless to really help
they knew the time was passing no night
was coming
their father would be angry there would
be concern
they had to get home which was half an
hour away on
on the horse and then
images came into their heads and they
were
sort of mesmerized and frozen
to the spot they saw big buildings
falling apart of course they had never
seen
a big building there on a farm in new
mexico in 1945
they they see things falling from the
sky
and then in later years
they have recurring dreams about things
falling from the sky
people dying people falling from
buildings and
that lasted in the case of mr padilla
this lasted about two or three years he
had these recurring dreams afterwards
but they are essentially mesmerized and
frozen to the spot
they jose
mr padilla wants to go and help
and remy says no way i'm not going there
and the older one defers to
the younger one and they they don't go
there
they go they go home at night on
horseback
crying all the way kevin do you have any
questions for jacques about this
or insights where to start um
wow um earlier i was kind of laughing
because
the story about the tower
and how it acted it was supposed to act
as kind of a warning to
pilots about the cliff um the fact that
the
craft hit the warning tower i thought
was kind of ridiculous
um it misses the cliff but hits the wall
kind of ironic right um well there is no
question that something hit the tower
yeah yeah some time later the
army just took down the tower it's not
there
right so that's why i reacted
probably visibly to that um the
now i i definitely agree with what you
say about the
young boys being
responsible you know they're responsible
enough to go and
and collect information on cattle and
and drive a truck and that and i i'm
not i didn't grow up in the 1940s but i
grew up in the 1970s and
and and we had i grew up in wisconsin
and we
um we had a great deal more freedom than
than
kids typically do today and i think that
you know we could
i was i was able to ride my bike
10 miles out into the country without
any problems and to go bird watching or
butterfly collecting or whatever i was
up to at the time so
so that was not a real issue back then
and and we were able to do that
and um so that's not so surprising to me
now
the um
so the the the few things come to mind
and
and well a lot of things so the
description of the
beings is of course very similar to what
you
we hear over and over again and um
and there's been some question as to are
these things
really biological are they you know are
they machines
are they you know and what and so
the fact that you know the fact that
they were
um distressed i find interesting it
makes me
think that they're you know really are
biological
and um although you could have a
distressed machine if it's sufficiently
intelligent i suppose so
but then it'd be like that simpsons joke
with the robot coming out of the burning
building why
why did you design me to feel pain
that's right
that's right yeah you can yeah that's
right
and um we're rutger hauer's character
and blade runner who doesn't want to die
right he
so he goes to his maker and wants more
life and he's clearly distressed and
disturbed so
um yeah that could happen but
so the the another thing really strikes
me
strange is the idea that they don't walk
that they kind of shuffle or will
themselves to move to
point to point and i that i've heard you
know from multiple accounts as well
um they either are hovering just above
the ground
and just kind of willing themselves from
place to place and
and i can't help but think what what's
going on there
what is what is happening with that and
if they're
you know if they're truly biologic if
they're just biological then how are you
doing that how can you possibly do
something like that
um and so it makes me wonder maybe
there's a
you know some kind of maybe there's a
technology involved
and maybe there's you know you can i
guess you could probably
at this point humans aren't totally
biological we have
appendages which are made right so i've
glasses um these are probably the oldest
ones but
you know we'll have cyborgs soon where
we have actually actually
extra equipment attached um you have
headphones on
so this is basically it so
so there could be something
technological to that which would then
make that you know possibly more
believable
although i still wouldn't know how it
would work
um the
the consciousness aspect is very strange
and
and surprising the um
and of course those accounts are very
similar to other accounts
especially i had um
seen salma sayak i believe her name is
who
from who was in the ariel school in
zimbabwe
yes and um and she was
very close to one of these small beings
again and she talked about
um an eyelock where where you your eyes
lock onto theirs and you are mesmerized
and and really can't move can't turn
away you
paralyzed almost and um being mesmerized
is probably the
the word that i hear most and um
and very often people describe you get
thoughts and forms of images you get
images flashing in your mind
and very often these are images very
similar to
you know disaster fires buildings
crashing exactly what you're describing
so
do you have any ideas to why that may be
kevin and jock first of all are they
even premonitions are they examples of
what may occur in the future
or are they just images like that are
disconnected and and why
and why it's it's to be honest it sounds
very
biblical um it sounds very much like you
know the revelations from john
or something it doesn't say it doesn't
sound that different actually you know
it makes me more sometimes wonder maybe
maybe this is what john's encounter was
like and
and he had visions like this and wrote
them down
um could that be what happened there
mr padilla said uh told me they were
putting images into my mind yeah so he
felt there was
there was communication there even
though he didn't
walk up to it they didn't especially
look
directly at them that there was this
intense
intense community feeling of of
communication
the the same thing happens in in
valencia uh
with the the the witness there uh
in valencia the the witness is a former
leader of the french resistance
so he is um and
you know just so interesting that
i i know you have an audience here of
scientists and scientists say well
you know the the witnesses must have
told what they saw because
they they go to the police and they
write a report
they give a report that's not true in
with ufo cases
it's not true with the traumatic cases
number one there are things that the
witnesses don't remember
or cannot articulate you have
which is why people rightly or wrongly
try to use hypnosis which is not a good
idea
but some of the information is buried in
the unconscious
uh no carl jung speaks about that uh
and some of the information that you
know will you go to the
local police uh and tell them
well you know i i saw this and then they
put images in my mind you know i mean
the you know the local guy will say okay
i've got 10 robberies to investigate
don't bother me with
the you know the things you see in your
mind so
and also these witnesses had good
reasons not to
talk about what they had seen and and to
to some extent they would have repressed
it except that they
kept talking about it among themselves
okay and then after that as they grew up
they went to different
uh mr padilla went to the korean war
uh has a couple of bullets in his body
by the way
uh from both his life as a you know with
the
california highway patrol
and with uh korea
uh so these these are serious people and
um ray me baca went on a career as a
businessman
in in the state of washington they
practically forgot the case they
you know they let it drift away from
them
and they were reconnected by
one of the one of their kids doing an
internet
search uh about the
history of their family and they found
each other through
through an internet search and then
they reconstructed they said you
remember when we saw this and
you know whatever happened to that case
and so on
and then they that's when the case was
mentioned in a
local paper in new mexico and that's
where paola harris found it
and started investigating from italy
where she was living
and then went to visit um
remy baka and got the whole got the
whole story
so that's that's how it happened so i'm
a little bit
intimidated speaking to an audience of
of scientists because you know
the the people here have a right to say
well
so we've got the thing it landed you've
got the witnesses
surely you have some answers where did
it come from why did it hit the tower
what was it made of and so on well
the problem is that yes we have some
answers
but there is only so far that i can go
i i can tell you that these people are
telling the truth i can tell you that we
have corroborating data
from you know the other
two other witnesses um i can tell you
that
we've actually recovered some some
some things uh that we certainly have
good descriptions of the physics
of some of the objects that were
recovered
that that are very interesting in terms
of the the property of the materials
including memory metals i mean people
talk about memory metals
in roswell you know two years later and
yes i mean people at battelle and other
places
working for industry had thought of an
aerospace
of course we're thinking of memory
metals that could be used in
actuators in airplanes and rockets and
all those things and yes they were aware
of the discoveries that had been made in
physics
about metal that can come back to its
own
shape to its original shape under
certain conditions of temperature
whatever
but in 1945 you know an operational
memory metal
that's you know you can argue about 1947
1945 it's a lot harder you know but
of course we don't know what was in the
research labs
but essentially what what we have opens
up
other questions remember at the end
of on the last day the army
again an army officer
goes to see the father of
mr padilla and he says in spanish
we're going to have to cut your fence
and we have your permission again the
army can't just go there
it's leased from the bureau of land
management
you know the official federal agency
so uh they have to ask permission to the
owner
uh or to to the the man who manages the
property he says
why do you want to cut the fence i mean
there is a gate there
for the cattle and this officer
says yeah but we need to bring a big
truck
to recover this experimental balloon
okay that fell on your property well
everybody knows
i mean there were balloons that i mean
they were launching balloons all the
time at white sands
the balloons fell on his 80 000 acres
so he was he had a bunch of balloons in
the back room
that he gave this officer said you want
your balloons or
here they are you know they they were
recovering weather balloons all the time
on this land okay so it was a big joke
and everybody knew it wasn't a balloon
okay so
we need to bring this big truck to
recover this quote balloon
and we have to cut your fence but we
will give you a big gate
that you can use you know and we'll
build a road
so the first thing the army has to do is
to go there and he agreed
uh go there cut the fence put in their
own gate
and and bring a couple of graders to
build a road to
which is i i've walked on that road uh
you know it's it's about a mile or so
to the place where the object was
resting
then they bring this 18-wheeler with a
low boy
where they can load this object on its
side
so they have to build a crane
which was probably about 15 to 20 feet
high
it's not a big crane but it has to be
big enough to lift this thing and put it
sideways um remember it's sort of egg
shaped but if we put it
right up it's not going to go under the
overpass
on the way back to white sands okay so
this
is not a weather balloon okay this is a
big object
it's like the size of a large you know a
large truck
and uh about 25 feet long about 15 feet
high
the kids measure it okay again those are
smart
kids they they measure it not with a
tape but they measure it by pacing it
and it's 20 to 25 feet long
15 feet high i asked mr padilla how
high was it inside and he said about 13
feet
and i say huh you know i mean you were
three feet tall i mean you were
nine year old how do you know it was 13
he says because that's
the size of the beams when you build a
house
okay this is a nine-year-old this is a
very sharp
nine-year-old he knows the facts of life
okay uh
again he had a reference object in his
mind and he had a reference
jacques a question from the audience
from two people one is f
is me and amjad hussein by the way amjad
hussein is
the ceo of algo.com which i recommend
you check out because they sponsor the
podcast they both have the same
question which is about aliens and
consciousness
is there the possibility of connecting
to aliens through psychedelics
have you experimented with this or know
about people who have done this
and why do you think this may be
plausible
this is to both of you even kevin uh
terence mckenna is a reference on this
has
done a lot of research on as you know in
psychedelics
all over the world i've spoken to his
brother as well
and there are quite a few people who go
off to
mexico or to brazil to experiment with
different things and they describe
beings that they call aliens that they
think of as aliens
when they are under the effect of uh of
the psychedelic
uh i've never taken any drugs so i'm not
you know not even tobacco
i mean i tried once and i i didn't like
it so
so i smoke on a regular basis well yeah
but you know
that's maybe that's why they kicked me
out but
uh i'm you know i've never had any
curiosity for this but i think it's
certainly valid
science and valid you know brain
research
obviously one thing that discouraged me
was
working with medical people who were
experimenting with advanced
pharmaceuticals and so on
and and what they described was
you know uh
drugs that our own neural system
generates you know that can take
complete control of the mind and the
body
and uh so the the drugs that people
describe for
an entertainment uh sort of uh mundane
compared to what the normal you know
what today
today's pharmacology can do and so
yes i believe that people have those
experiences
but when i ask them can you the next
time you
you you take the drug does it take you
back to the same place can you talk to
the same people
no it's different things every time
that's entertainment that's dreams
okay that i don't deal with that you
know what
the ufo witnesses give me things that
can calibrate
i mean the three cases that are
described in the book have been
researched officially by governments
in the french case there were five
different agencies
that did research on valencia including
the french customs
including the the french equivalent of
the fbi
uh including the army including the
police and the jean armory
separately so those were not
you know those were calibrated and what
they described we can
we can compare to other cases like
socorro
like this case where we have the
equivalent
level of information that's calibrated
and uh you know that people take
ketamine
or they take some drug in in mexico
and they come back with these
astonishing stories
and i believe them but again those are
not things that are repeatable
i can't find a pattern that i can work
with kevin what about you do you see any
validity to the
proposition that you can ingest
psychedelics and speak to alien life or
that alien life is somehow
associated with deep meditative
altered states of consciousness
um i'm not i don't know the first thing
about psychedelics
so um zero i really can't speak to that
but you're asking two different
questions there i mean one question is
can we use pharmacology
to approximate those conditions the
other question is can
normal consciousness have access to
other forms of consciousness that's a
different question
right yeah so i mean if you're if you're
i guess my
my statement would be that if you are
doing something like this
then you are not interacting with
another
biological entity per se
you're interacting with another
consciousness um
if there isn't any interaction at all if
it's not a dream or an
you know hallucination and so
i think there's just way too much to
unpack there and
that would require some careful some
very careful study which
i'm not i don't know anything about it
there's a question from raul ranjan who
said this is directed to you
jacques you said that the universe is
nothing but
mental reality which perceives
information structures
which seems first of all is that true
and then second it seems similar to
donald hoffman's
theories about consciousness and
conscious agents it's also similar to
thomas campbell if you've heard of him
have you heard of those two individuals
and
and do you mind restating that theory
that
all that there is is mental states with
an interaction between data structures
uh okay saying
mental states is different from saying
information structures in physics
you and i have been taught
that energy and information are two
sides of the same coin
okay and in that ted
talk you know uh i
started from that to to say
yes we can talk about
you know the theory of everything but
when people say that
they are doing the theory of energy
you know atoms and particles and so on
they are not talking about consciousness
so when i said i want i want a theory of
everything else
i'd like a theory of the other side
which is information
there should be a theory of information
that should be equivalent to the theory
we have of energy
and we should we need to we need both of
them
to make sense of the universe okay now
you could
you could do a fear of the universe
without ever talking about energy you're
speaking to the right person
kevin knuth is the editor-in-chief of
entropy magazine or entropy journal
well uh the uh
you know certainly that that's the main
that's mainstream physics
saying that you know information and
energy are two sides of the same
same coin that's what i was trying to
address in uh
in brussels with that ted uh
presentation
the so you can that gives
us a chance to approach it from from the
other direction from the information
structure
direction and as you may know there are
people
now both at mit and in silicon valley
who are publishing books saying
what we think we see of the universe is
a video game
it's just a video game so the first
reaction is
wait i mean you know things are
much more what i see and i can apprehend
it's much more complex than anything is
in a video game but think again uh
you know can you project what a video
game technology is going to be
five years ten years from now uh with
immersion immersion total immersion
um yes well i from here
i cannot see the eiffel tower but i'm
going to be in france in a month
i will see the eiffel tower all i can
see now is
the the screens in front of me and you
i know there are things behind me
but i don't see them i only see them
by looking at the screen you know that
shows the things behind me
but i can simulate that today with a pc
i mean
that's not a problem and i can make you
think that you're really there
okay certainly with one of the the game
machines
you know it's not a problem with the
semiconductor technology we've got today
okay so uh and when you talk about the
simulations that they use to train
pilots or to train surgeons you know
that's
a hundred times better than that so yes
we can immerse you
in in a situation where you would not be
able to tell
reality from the simulation and
that's you know obviously very scary but
uh
that's the world where we're creating
right now
and so the the question of
approaching it from the information
structure
standpoint is interesting and the
the question is without going all the
way there
the the question remains is somebody or
something
in the universe you know with no
preconception that there are
spaceships uh i mean this this doesn't
look like a spaceship i mean
you know it did the controls were very
simple
if there were controls there was
practically nothing inside
there was no kitchen there were no
toilet facilities there was none of
the things that people look for when
they think of ufos as a spacecraft okay
none of that so but neither do our cars
and we would call our cars some sort of
vehicle of transportation
well we we don't know what it is uh
it could be a donation uh why does it
have the same shape as
two other objects that were used in the
manhattan project
uh you know the the container for the
experimental explosions which they call
jumbo was the same size and the same
shape it was built by
you know the manhattan project to
contain nuclear explosions
it was never used that way but i've seen
it i've gone there and touched it
it's uh you know about eight eight
inches
thick of steel all the way around um
it was brought in with a special you
know
trailer with many many uh mini wheels
all the way from ohio
uh that the object that crashed that's
sort of the same shape
uh it has the same shape as the bomb i
have a question for
sorry for both of you do you have any
ideas or speculations as to what the
intent
are of these aliens or ufos
firstly can they be classified as such
are there multiple species and maybe
they have
contrary motives what do you think
kevin if you don't mind
and then
i think it's at this point it's still
quite difficult because
we have
it's not clear that you're dealing with
a single phenomenon
um and we're we're very likely
conflating
multiple you know multiple phenomena
and so that's very probably
why we we are having trouble pinning
things down
and saying oh it's it's this and not
that
um because in some cases it may be maybe
um case a and might there might also be
case b
so i think that at this point we just
we're very ignorant as to what's going
on and
um this ignorance has been
you know perpetuated by our government
who insists on studying these things
secretly
which we now know that they've been
doing for years um they've
they've made that very clear with the
coming out of the a-tip program and the
fact that
congress has to collect information from
the intelligence agencies
um where did that information come from
if they hadn't been studying this
so we know we know that they've been
studying it secretly
um and congress doesn't even know about
it so
there's a lot of ignorance here and it's
also perpetuated by scientists who are
more interested in just
just believing the whole thing
altogether and and washing their hands
of it and not wanting to look at the
problem
so i've i've really come to appreciate
people i'll often claim oh the you know
people the believers
you know there's a strong desire to
believe but what i've really found is
that
people don't like changing their world
views they're very uncomfortable
changing their
world view and the desire to not believe
is far stronger than the desire to
believe
um and and of course with science it
isn't
shouldn't be about belief it should be
about knowing but
you see more scientists are more
there are so many scientists who are
more than willing to write editorials
talking about how skeptical they are
um where they haven't actually looked at
the problem
and so they're more interested in saying
i'm skeptical i don't believe
um then they are curious there's a
surprising lack of curiosity here which
um
really that shouldn't that shouldn't
happen in science and certainly not when
you have some
you know fascinating stories like this
and fascinating anecdotes like this
it's not there's something very wrong
here
and i think it's the fact that people
don't want their world views changed
they don't want to believe this
and it's now i don't think
that proving that something is alien is
going to be
proving something's extraterrestrial is
going to be really incredibly difficult
i you know we already have some
information about the uap task report
and you know and and there's been some
statements made that they're
yeah they're not saying that there's
proof that they are extraterrestrial but
they can't rule it out either and that's
exactly what i would have expected
because
um how do you prove that something is
extraterrestrial everything in the
universe is made of the same stuff
you could do studies of isotopes
and that could be informative but it
doesn't it's not conclusive because
we can isolate different isotopes here
and create materials with
different isotopes we don't we don't
typically do that it would be horribly
expensive and so you'd be surprised if
that were the case but
but it doesn't rule it out so i i often
joke that to prove that one of these
things is extraterrestrial you're into
to prove that to everybody you're going
to have to almost
drag an alien off of one of these craft
on live television kicking and screaming
you know for everyone to say oh yeah
clearly this is extraterrestrial
that's pretty much what you're gonna
have to do before people
will have to be forced to believe this
before they have to give up on this
desire to not believe
um so but i think at this point we have
a lot of
there is no smoking gun you know as
michio kaku has talked about the smoking
gun
and there's not going to be a smoking
gun it's not going to happen
you're going to get lots of little
pieces of information
and some of this information is going to
be more reliable
like materials research than other types
of information which would be anecdotal
types of information and yeah the
reliability varies but you can still
make inferences from lots of little
pieces of information we're not stupid
we can use our brains and we can assess
the information assess how
valid we think the different pieces are
and we can get somewhere with that
and that's what i'm trying to do here
and
and it's difficult because a lot of this
these
anecdotes are really shocking and
surprising and different it's
we're not just looking at changing your
world view
with respect to one topic
um that and that isn't j so it clearly
isn't just that oh there are
there exist extraterrestrials exist
that isn't the only thing i'm going to
have to try to believe i'm going to have
to now also
deal with the fact that they can they
can will themselves from place to place
in some cases
they can communicate telepathically in
some
cases or or transmit images and things
like this and
and the motivations of course are
entirely foreign to us so it's it's
the the whole thing is is in some ways
it's a mess but
but as a scientist it's a fascinating
mess i mean
this is this is exactly what you want to
come across when
i mean when you go into science when i
when i first went into science i
i was disappointed because as i'm
learning more and more about physics i
i'm realizing there's nothing to
be done it's all been studied and all
the interesting stuff's been done and
studied and and
i really wanted to learn about space and
time and i was disappointed learning
about relativity and general relativity
i thought einstein did it all already
what
am i going to do and and it took me a
long time
years and decades to be able to figure
out well it hasn't all been figured out
and there is stuff to still do
but um to have events like this thrown
at you
is exactly what you wanted i mean which
what what you dream of when you start
out being a scientist
here's something entirely foreign that
nobody knows
anything about um
and go at it see what we can learn
that's
that's exactly what you would like to
have as a scientist and that's what you
would have imagined
galileo felt like you know he first
pulls out the telescope
that he made and now let's look at the
sky and see what i can find
that's that's how exciting was that
um and now we're we're in that same
situation and and
there are scientists jumping on board
now now that it's
clear that these things are are
physically real um
and that's changed but the amount the
curiosity still isn't there
which to me is really shocking um i
don't know
what's broken within the scientific
community but i
very much of it is probably because
we've been told
since birth you know for most of us that
this this is nonsense um we've been
taught that by
you know by other scientists we've been
taught that by our teachers told that by
our parents
and by the authorities and now we find
out that the authorities
know it's not nonsense and they've not
been treating it like nonsense
um and we're still having trouble
getting our heads around this well
okay so clearly there's something and
and the most science most scientists
have
just simply conceded which was the first
thing i was
felt comfortable doing was that all
right well certainly it's something that
should be studied
um but you still see most scientists
saying but i'm not gonna do it
well what kind of scientist are you i
mean what you're not
you're not hungry for a cool discovery
when i presented um my
my paper on the um flight
characteristics of uaps
at the muck splunk institute at the
mexican conference there
you know i started out by saying you
know asking the question
why on earth would i be looking at this
and
um getting into this and
the answer is simple because there's
discoveries to be made here
and to be this close to it and have that
opportunity
and then just let it pass by
i'm going to be kicking i would be
kicking myself for years you know for
the rest of my life why didn't i take
the time to even look at that
you know and that's how i that's what i
felt and i
really did some soul searching and
thought no i'm gonna study this i'm
you know i'm now 57 years old i have a
good
easily attend another 10 years probably
of research in me maybe
hopefully more but um i've done some
good work
on in other topics and why not have some
fun and look at something that's brand
new
that no one knows anything about and
let's see what we can learn from that
and i think that's really exciting
so i'm really wavered i
sped off in a totally different
direction with almost impossible
acceleration there
so let me go back to your your
um your what your original question was
um had to do with um the motive behind
these
motives behind can you even ascribe one
motive because it may be
a multiplicity of phenomenon rather than
just one
and i don't know i mean the the simplest
explanation
that that seems to cover
much of the of what's observed is
that they are very possibly
extraterrestrial visiting earth
you know in spacecraft um
why would you think that well the
beings that are observed appear to be
biological but they're not human
and we don't see them here on earth
other than during these events
so they very are thought to be up from
elsewhere
um the craft behave
as i said before with from the
especially from the estimates we
performed these craft move like
spaceships should move
um they move at speeds and ex they move
at speeds
that our spacecraft move ahead
so to think that they're not spacecraft
would be kind of silly
um they're very potentially very much
potentially spacecraft
so um but
we have we observed them moving in space
well we don't
i don't know that yet so that's an
important question there
so jacques have we do you know of any
cases where
we've seen ufo in space and also about
the motive question your speculations
from there's there um there's a few
cosmonauts who've reported
ufos from space and there are um and
i think it's um um cosmonaut often yes
actually had drawings of a a an
object that pulled up alongside their
spaceship on the
way to one of the solute stations
so there have been there have been some
and and there have been sightings from
skylab and shuttles as well of of
more ambiguous objects so so potentially
these things have been observed in space
but
but i don't think that we've observed
the same where we can
confidently say these are the same
objects you know this is an
egg-shaped object you know that crashed
in new mexico looks
you know what i saw from my spacecraft
window looks the same thing as what
you know lonnie zamora reported i don't
think we are in that situation
jacques what about what your thoughts
are
i've heard both sides of that um
you know had the uh the privilege of
working with uh
ed mitchell at uh on on the board of uh
you know one of the
the groups that have tried to to advance
the study of uh
of the subject and he of course
would be trusted by his fellow
astronauts and
especially the the ones who went to the
moon
uh the apollo the apollo cadre
um and uh yes he reported
that they had seen things but they would
not
report it officially um
one one astronaut was a general
um who had been in in space several
times
photographed an object that he described
as a ufo
uh with a his hasselblad camera um
when they landed um
[Music]
and i served on on the board at the
university of michigan with him
at one time uh the
nasa of course when you when you land
they take everything that's on the
spacecraft and it goes to different labs
right away and so on so
he didn't the camera was taken away
from him and everything else and uh
he asked to see his photograph
and at first they wouldn't give it to
him
i'll discuss it and he insisted
because he had the seniority to tell the
technicians that he wanted to
the photograph and they gave him a
picture that
he said under the record
that wasn't the picture he took
and this was an object that was close to
the spacecraft
on the way to the moon
tracking apollo
now what was it
uh you know the uh
yes you can argue about pictures you can
argue all day long
about pictures was it some part that
had detached itself from the spacecraft
was flying along but
it didn't fly along i mean it went away
so
and he had taken a picture and didn't
recognize
the photograph that they gave him
and he was actually very irate about
that that whole thing
that he was trusted to you know to pilot
the spacecraft to the moon that he was
entrusted to look at his own picture
and that's that's uh you know there is
another case like that in the book that
you mentioned about a physical object
that was analyzed by nasa
and then nasa was superseded by another
agency and the men who had
entrusted the sample to
never had the right answer and and we
know that
he was given a lie not by nasa but nasa
was pushed aside
and somebody else took over so the
question is
um you know what the subject in new
mexico i mean obviously
that was real and it was
waiting a few times where did it go and
how come dr heineck didn't know about it
how come nobody in the air force knew
about it then when
you know i spent two days at
wright-patterson air force base
with the air force project blue book
team
with dr heineck and uh by the way none
of that was classified i mean very very
little of it
was classified and you know scientists
could have had access to it all along
and when i read the the report from the
task force
you know i have this deja vu you know
forgive my french but
this deja vu impression of you know
those were things that the air force had
said in the 50s
you know yeah there are things we don't
understand them
people should report them we don't know
what they are i mean that's
essentially what the you know this navy
report is saying
well come on i mean you know what have
we done the last 50 years
so i mean those are questions the
scientific community should be asking
now my understanding is that the report
was changed
i had a chance to talk to some of the
people
close to on on zoom some of the people
who were at the origin of that
report and the report has changed over
over the last few months from a public
report to a classified report so
those of the audience who have the right
access
may have a chance to look at their the
actual report
what the public is being given now is
just a very superficial overall
statement which is
you know which is i think is true i mean
it's sincere
that there is something flying around
that we don't
understand but that's what the air force
the u.s air force was saying in 1947.
so come on i mean what happened i mean
what happened to
billions of dollars of our tax money i
mean what
what are these guys doing and and you
have to
worry because the i mean this is what
happens when you don't
involve you know scientists in the
scientific community and study these
things openly
and here we are you know and here i find
myself even you know how waiting you
know in anticipation to see this report
as if we're going to get any kind of
information that's
trustworthy or meaningful um we've heard
the the
tired old mantra of it was a weather
balloon
over and over and over again you know
there was a weather balloon
in trinity seriously you need a truck to
carry a weather balloon
equipment away why wouldn't you just tie
another weather a balloon to it
hoist it up with a few cables and then
let it float while you drive it away
with a jeep
you can easily do that if it's a weather
balloon i mean it's it's silly
it's a weather balloon that needs a
crane to lift give me a break
that's dumb and we're not we're not all
that stupid
and and give people a little more credit
than that you know skeptics are going to
glom onto whatever they want they can
glom onto because
a sufficiently motivated skeptic can
deny anything
and there's flat earthers out there
let's just throw that there
so so now you know in the whole roswell
situation too those we were supposed to
know there have been like three
different stories that the air force
told about roswell
and now you know the one is now it's
project mogul and it was weather boom
with a ra with a little
little also wood aluminum foil radar
reflectors
that left a three-quarter mile long
debris field that was
200 feet wide really
um what kind of how many of these things
did you launch and how did they all
crash in the same place or how big was
this radar reflector um
you have to use a forest of balsa trees
to
build something this big it's ridiculous
um
and it's in it's it's silly that you
know we've
somehow accepted these these these
stories and they really are just stories
um you know who's who's being ridiculous
at these this point
it's it's our government who's been
lying to us who feels the need to
classify these things that
um and can't possibly tell us what's
going on yet these things
do yet these things do pose an
air traffic hazard um not only military
pilots see them but commercial pilots
see them
commercial pilots see them with
passengers in the plane
um you've got planes full of 200
passengers and one of these things from
screaming past the windscreen of a
commercial jet in the past
and what are the pilots gonna do
eventually somebody's gonna panic
and i can't fault them because they've
not been trained to look for these
things
they've not been taught what they are
they've not been taught to not worry
about them
these things don't you know obey our air
traffic rules
um they're not atmospheric phenomena i'm
sorry you don't have atmospheric
phenomena whipping along
it at 100 g accelerations
um 60 times the speed of sound that's
that's dumb
the the whole atmospheric phenomena is
basically a retooling of the swamp gas
the old tired old saw gas mantra so
i mean so we're getting hearing that
from more skeptics i think the
nasa administrator talked yesterday or
the other day about
there's a possibility these are
atmospheric phenomena well
some of them may be atmospheric
phenomena but not the ones we should be
worried about
and i think that's really a problem here
well even if they are you know they are
a
plasma for example uh they are that's
interesting because we don't know
what a plasma is we we have no model for
why something like that with that much
energy
should just you know fly around your
bedroom i mean
there is no physical theory for that
that is a great example because when i
gave my talk
and uap character fight characteristics
at that meeting in
germany there was another speaker who
spoke about
ball lightning he was talking about
theoretical work on ball lightning
and he went into some detail complaining
about the fact that he can't publish
any of his work on ball lightning
because
ball lightning is a taboo topic in
physics
so so so it's
it i think it's again ironic that you're
going to have that a lot of scientists
basically when encountering the ufo
phenomena
because that's so taboo oh we'll just
say it's ball lightning but ball
lightning is actually another taboo
topic that is not well understood
generally so um you're just trading one
unknown
for another unknown and nobody's getting
anywhere this isn't
this isn't how science is supposed to
work well what
what those kids saw suddenly was not
ball lightning yeah
you don't need a crane it's not a
weather balloon either so
now you have you have some big questions
here
there's a question from zenex301 and
this can go to both of you
this person wants to know if there's any
compelling data or video that you've
seen that
has yet to be declassified
well if there was and
i would had seen it when i had
security clearance i still wouldn't be
able to
talk about it um
the i've certainly heard
you know about cases like that
but the the larger point
is still true that the skeptics are
making
i mean there are there are well-informed
skeptics that
who that we need in this discussion is
mick west one of them
a well-informed skeptic mcquest
um i well i could
certainly some of the some of the panel
that professor stuart gathered that
under you know the rockefeller the
foundation support uh
were came away interested but still
skeptical because they said you haven't
given me anything i can take to my lab
you know and that's that's a valid okay
but they spent a week
listening to us make a number of
presentations
about you know the different aspects of
the of the problem and the statistics
and everything else
uh with people in the room from the us
from france
and elsewhere so and this was funded by
the rockefeller foundation
it's been published and uh that's
you know what i would call the skeptical
viewpoint there are people who've argued
with me
and have taught me some things that
where i had to recognize they were right
and i was wrong
about certain cases i mean that's how we
learn okay
but the um the the the larger point
is why don't we have a lot of pictures
and in some cases
the witnesses say you know i watched
this for half an hour
and it went away and then i realized i
had my camera on the back seat of the
car
and i never thought about you know
taking it
uh the other cases people took a picture
and it was sort of fuzzy
so you can say well maybe it's an
interdimensional
craft and it doesn't really exist in our
reality all the time
yeah you can sort of rationalize it but
it it's a good question
and you know there are people like
dr haines dr richard haynes from nasa
who has
gathered a number of photographs
and but the photograph is only a
photograph i mean
you can always argue that there was some
artifact
you know so it's not
that that's true we don't we don't have
photographic evidence that's
that's really good
good to the point of being convincing to
a jury of your peers or you know you're
watching this channel because you're
interested in theoretical physics
consciousness and the ostensible
connection between the two what's
required to follow some of these
arguments is
facility with mathematics as well as
discernment of the underlying physical
laws and
you may think that this is beyond you
but that's false brilliance provides
pelucid explanations of abstruse
phenomenon such as
quantum computing general relativity and
even group theory when you hear that the
standard model is based on u1
cross su 2 cross su 3 that's group
theory for example now this isn't just
for neophytes either
for example i have a degree in math and
physics and i still found
some of the intuitions given in these
lessons to vastly aid my penetration
into these subjects for example
electricity and magnetism sign up today
at brilliant.org slash toe that is t-o-e
for free you'll also get 20 off the
annual premium subscription
try four of the lessons at least don't
stop before four
and i think you'll be greatly surprised
at the ease at which you comprehend
subjects you previously had trouble
grocking
links are in the description one
question is about peer review
when can we expect more peer-reviewed
publications on this phenomenon that's
by
harry austin we are working on one
actually uh that the
research is done it has been referee
and we're ready to publish it but we
don't want to pre-announce
the the publication so we hope it will
be out this summer
kevin what about you what do you think
when what will it take for more
peer-reviewed
studies to be done on this phenomenon
yeah well we're working on
papers as well and i'm working on
collecting our own data at this point
as well i'm working with the uapx group
and we have several
military grade flir infrared cameras
long wave infrared and we are
basically at this point just watching
the skies with them
um recording data and then going back
through it to see what we can find
and we have um especially our engineer
in washington state has um recorded
multiple images of objects that we can't
identify
so and one of these in fact was
was following a jet airplane so we have
and these things are anomalous as well
they're they're um
we found that they're very cold compared
to
um to a jet airplane say
our machines are hot they make they run
they make heat it's thermodynamics but
um are they room temperature sorry are
they
the temperature of the air around them
or are they slightly colder or slightly
warm yeah they're quite cold
and so they're so the one that i'm
thinking about right now
was about 60 degrees below zero
fahrenheit so negative 60 fahrenheit
so it's great photographs depends what
the altitude is and it so it could be
similar to the ambient temperature at
that altitude but we don't know what the
altitude was in that case so we're
we're going to be taking um more careful
videos in the near future and hopefully
be able to do some triangulation
so kevin speaking of photographs what's
the picture
behind you on the wall on your wall
behind your
right shoulder oh i think that's just a
reflection of a light
fixture in his home that's a light
reflection okay
i was hoping you had the ultimate flying
saucer there
there's like a castle on a mountain top
but it's a that's that's a light
reflection from
from these lights up here you know
that shows how you can be fooled by
ordinary objects and you're in you're
and you're absolutely right i was very
negative about skeptics earlier and
and what i really should have clarified
is that i was
you know talking about extraordinary
skepticism extreme skepticism
i mean we need a healthy amount of
skepticism of course
many the scientists now there's 600
people watching this
just so you know jacques i thought it
would only be 200 there's 600 right now
wow and plenty of the audience of this
channel they're physicists and
mathematicians they're extremely bright
but
also at the same time i don't know why i
say but
and also at the same time they're
extremely open otherwise they wouldn't
be watching this
well you know i think that all that is
needed
is for science to be given permission to
look at this
i'm not you know i've worked
occasionally as you know on
classified projects and they were
legitimate
and there there is i i'm not
you know saying that everything should
have been open right away
in the conditions of the cold war for
example in 1945
nobody knew what that thing was it was
taken away and it was classified
and remember one of the canadian
scientists who looked at all this was
told
by american authorities that the subject
was classified higher than the atom bomb
and was legitimately classified higher
than the atom bomb
and i i don't really have a problem with
it
given the the conditions at the time
there was the expectation that we could
quickly maybe master the
technology before the russians
you know there were alerts all the time
about
the possibility of nuclear war with uh
with russia
you know as late as the the cuban crisis
certainly we came very
very very very close to it so
um there is legitimacy
in giving it to uh
you know under classification to labs
that could
and i can imagine the things that our
witnesses described
coming out of this 1945 case being
separated you know the fiber given to uh
you know a glass lab this
part of a craft description given to
battelle
especially the you know the pliable
material the memory metal
that we know battelle was working on and
has been patented since then so i mean
we we can
look at the track uh some of it went to
ibm
i know that because some ibm people have
told me about some of the things
they had looked at but this is not
you know it's difficult to do science at
that
high level of classification because you
have to parcel out the material
and in science i mean the whole point is
you get people to talk
together you did you need an
interdisciplinary
if there are if there is biological
material there
you know the physicists should know
about it i mean when you design a
spacecraft
for people you design it differently
than if you did
you know uh if nobody is going if there
isn't going to be a pilot
i mean that's the whole point of the
discussion but
about what we should do in space you
know today or we should what we should
do on the moon
if we send people it's going to cost a
lot more if we send
ai you know there are other things we
can do
those should be part of the discussion
and today i mean
the russians to their credit have been
i wouldn't say they've been open but
there have been times
when they were a lot more open than we
were
they've had three different task forces
working on this from different
sides including experts on plasma by the
way
looking at the plasma aspects that
that are very very interesting and they
were
willing to open some of their facts
maybe it's time to set the
classification to review the
classification
and and look at it now why is it that
the air force never knew about this case
well uh there are three different paths
to false secrets in the us there is only
one that goes straight to the president
through the normal administration levels
okay it certainly would involve the
pentagon and it would go
straight to the president it would be on
the desk of the president
eventually if it's deemed that he
should be aware that's the the the
process that
everybody's knows about
including secret top secret sap and
everything else
there are two other two other systems
there is a system that
doesn't go to the president unless there
is a need to
to tell the president about it which has
to do with diplomatic relations
has to do with know other countries
diplomacy and that level of secrets goes
to the state department
and agencies related to the state
department
that's there is a high level of
classification obviously at that level
that it's not a direct path to
the things that people with a top secret
clearance
would necessarily have access you know
and then there is another level which is
the atomic secrets
our belief after reviewing all this and
talking to people
and reinterviewing the witnesses about
what their experience was in later years
was that this was remember this was on
the
territory on the piece of land that was
controlled
by project manhattan it wouldn't have
gone to the air force there was no air
force
there was an army air force that was
attached to the army
the army was working for project
manhattan under the currencies of
project manhattan
it would have gone
presumably to los alamos
then it would have been classified under
the p clearances
or the q clearances or there are
clearances
that go to the department of energy they
don't go to the air force
they don't go to the navy they don't go
to the president
and that's what people have never
understood that's why
you've never heard about it that's why
we call it the
you know the best kept secret the the
the witnesses never spoke about it for
75 years
and the government is not going to talk
about it
now we know that because remy baca
remy baka had a political role in the
state of washington
at what time and he got dixie lee ray
elected you know as part of her
political team at one time as governor
of washington
dixie lee ray was the secretary of
energy at one time
and she showed him the file
on his sighting she had the fire
and he flew with her to a convention
somewhere
and she knew about his experience as a
kid
and and the fact that um
that he had seen this and uh this is
somebody telling me not to talk about
this
the notification sound so this this
conversation is tell me
oh scare me we're live streaming though
so it doesn't matter
this is going to go out there no but the
um
uh you know she showed him the fight
about what what he had seen and
what what had been recovered she didn't
let him
take take notes from it but the you know
the file was classified
within and was classified
legitimately within the atomic
secrets and again people were
told that the ufo problem was classified
higher than the atomic sequence
someone here named jacob rumay wants to
know
for both of you to have have you and
have you encountered christopher mellon
or luis elizondo and if so
do you have any strong feelings as to
their legitimacy their sincerity
or do you sense an agenda um
i i know uh chris mellon
quite well uh we've spoken a number of
times here
and in in france uh i've had
dinner with him at my place in paris
with with we've talked about the sharing
of information and so on
um the uh and
uh i i admire you know the position that
he has taken
he certainly was in a position to
understand how the government
thinks about at that very high level
about things like this and his
obviously has been instrumental in
bringing out some of the information
including the nimitz photographs you
know to
to us i mean to the public uh i've never
met
uh mr elizondo i i admire the
you know the risk that he has taken with
his career
uh i think is intensely um
you know involved in this and and wants
to
to see an opening and wants to see
an involvement of the scientific
community i i
absolutely believe he's sincere and he
was in the
places where he was kevin
yeah i feel the same way i've not i've
not had the pleasure
of meeting chris fellain but um but i've
met
lou elizondo several times and spent
a bit of time talking to him about the
topic and
yeah he's he is
sincere and and passionate about this i
think he
he feels very strongly about this um
especially with regard to the pilots um
we have you know we have pilots who've
been encountering these things who've
had
you know problems encountering these
things and
and i think he's really looking out for
them to
get this resolved and figured out this
is really an air safety
issue in some cases and
it needs to be understood and so i think
he's sincere about that
he's and he is interested in getting the
scientific community involved
um he gave a presentation at the um
scientific coalition for uap studies at
cu's
conference two years ago
and um and i was there for that as well
so
so yes i i believe it's sincere
and hard to understand this
jacques have you done an any metallurgic
analysis of any of the objects
or materials that you managed to
capture take and if so are they
published in anywhere that people can
what are the results of that
so we are uh i've over the years people
have
given me you know samples
uh most of it is metallic i've i've
published a couple of papers about that
in in in the book i've done a summary
of what we've done so far
a number of people have done analyses
that were you know very uh high-level
competent analyses so we
we know what kinds of metals are
involved
as you may know professor sturak has
done isotope analysis of
a couple of samples especially of the
brazilian case at
ubatuba that's still an open question
we have the samples he's given them to
me
and we're going to redo that analysis in
fact we're doing that now
we're not quite ready to publish it we
have one paper
under review right now about about a
case where we
we have material and by the way after we
publish the paper we're willing to
share that material we have enough of it
that we could
um we could give to other teams to redo
the
the analyses and we're taking it to the
isotope level because
that that's a level where people cannot
cheat
you know or cannot be fooled by you know
some people can pick up a strange stone
you know in their field
after they've seen something in the sky
and make the connection
to test the connection if it's if it's
something ordinary and we can explain
why it was in the field then you know
that's probably not
a case that we should put a lot of uh
investment into on the other hand if the
isotope ratios are abnormal
then we should go back and look at it
some more
so we're doing that yes and regarding
the brazilian case someone had a
specific question davey
pacheco says wow nice man keep fighting
the good fight and asking the right
questions we all appreciate that
if possible please ask jacques what he
thinks about the
usually violent encounters in brazilian
cases um
the when you know i think
an anthropologist would say and i'm not
i'm not an anthropologist
but you become sort of an amateur
anthropologist after you speak to
a few a few thousand witnesses
you have to look at the cultural
conditions around
and some of the conditions in some
countries
are more towards a hostile reaction
to something you don't understand i mean
certainly in
in the u.s you know a number of these
things have been shot at
um but i mean you know
you see something really strange on your
ranch and you have a gun
uh you know you're that's in
in a way it's a natural thing to to
think of
uh and we're a culture where there are
lots of guns
the same thing is in brazil in in france
the reaction would be more one either
fear
or terror and running away uh but not
engaging it in terms of fighting with it
so
i think it's more of a reaction of a
reflection of the society
where you are and you know the part of
the country where you are
rather than the characteristic of the
object itself or the
you know the entity itself but there
have been cases where
yeah there were fights and there were
hostile
action i've gone through
the periphery of the amazon with people
in brazil
where investigators in brazil and
yes i've interviewed people who had been
not shot but had been hit by a beam
and had been injured by a beam that was
not
there is any kind of laser beam that we
can produce today
the beam you mentioned before in one of
the interviews that it comes out
rather than completely goes to the end
it comes out
and it's burning and it pins you you
know
some of these people were sleeping in a
hammock at night
in brazil which is what you do i mean
that's
uh in in the jungle and so on
farms many people sleep in hammocks
and the the the beam would pin them to
the
to the couch or to the hammer and the
beam had a physicality to it a pressure
to it
we have a regular laser wouldn't it we
have the pictures
of the the marks of the beam on the skin
because they see you know they see a
doctor doctor takes a picture we have
the pictures
and i've published them sorry kevin as a
physicist what do you think of that
well i i guess as i have another
question because it
sounds a lot like the um
the particle light beams that have been
observed by people who have been
been lifted up into craft or claim to
have been lifted up
they say that it's like a particular
light you know particles of light rather
than a light beam
um and makes me wonder if if that's the
situation i don't know how
you know a laser isn't going to pin you
to a hammock so something else is
clearly going on in that case
now there may be different frequencies
and different types of
of radiation involved i don't know how
you retract the light beam but
um yeah that's right that's right it
doesn't sound like any particles i'm
aware of so
you know from as
you know from a particle physics
perspective there would
there's probably something interesting
here
if the government has known about these
phenomena since the 40s
what's the reason that they're
disclosing this information right now
that comes from alan whitehead
that's a question for someone uh like uh
mr mellon uh you know uh assistant
secretary mellon
who had those discussions
at government level um
i think that in cases i know the
situation in france
every time we ask that question people
came back especially from the military
saying
uh you know it's not our job to create
panic or to interfere with people's
religious beliefs and so on
we you know that we respect that and
uh there are too many uh too many things
going on where we don't have the answer
and uh if we if we came out with that
uh people would be afraid
people might react in terror there might
be
political movements that couldn't be
controlled
and and we don't we couldn't provide the
government with any
guidance about what to do because we
don't understand
the phenomena
which is a fair answer is it majorly to
prevent
panic is that the primary reason
uh that's a reason that's given i i
think by now
it may have been true at one time you
know you've seen all these movies where
the aliens land and we shoot at them it
doesn't do any good
we bring the tanks and it doesn't do any
good we bring the atomic bomb and it
doesn't do any good
and then we've got zilla coming out of
the ocean
it destroys new york city so
yes that imagery is there i mean it's
certainly there in the cinema
and to some extent it's there in people
i mean
uh people have nightmares people have
now we've outgrown a lot of that i mean
we
today we might laugh at this and you
know say come on i mean
we've seen worse things and then
godzilla you know so
uh and uh even if it was godzilla well
you know we could probably
do something about it so it becomes
i wouldn't say it becomes a joke but
people are mature enough today
that it wouldn't have the same effect as
it would in the 50s
you know when kids were taught to hide
under the table
when the bomb went off and things like
that where there was a climate of terror
all the time
kevin what do you think
no i think that that makes a lot of
sense and and i agree with
shock in that this really is a question
that's best for somebody
like um chris mellon my impression
is that the navy has been having sincere
difficulties with this and um
the navy pilots it was reported
that in 215 they had near daily
encounters
um and that's a problem and i think they
have a
real problem on their hands that they
didn't have the ability to
easily talk about this to
um people higher up like the secretary
of defense so
so or people in congress so how do you
go
for how do you get assistance unless you
can talk more freely about this so i
think that
that probably would have to have
something to do with it that
that i'm getting congress involved
because you have a real problem on your
hands
um and so that's to me what looks like
what's going on
and and i would hope that you know as as
part of the answer
you know from the recommendation from
the uap task force that they recommend
that
you know we study these things
scientifically and openly and
and one of the ways they could support
this is provide a funding mechanism
um that would be interesting and it
doesn't you know it doesn't have to be
a lot probably um but it has but by
providing a funding mechanism
you would do a few things you would one
you would legitimize it
which would make it far easier for
scientists to to work on this and to
feel that they can work on this
and so they're going to be more people
because there are scientists who are
studying
studying this and many of them are doing
it quietly
because they worry about ridicule or
whatever so
because it still is a taboo topic so
by having some kind of funding stream
you would legitimize it
um it would then you know some
scientists who wanted to study this
would
see more support from their
administrators funding always helps
administrators make decisions
um and and so on and it would also give
them the ability to
um to actually do the work kevin and
jacques what does it mean
for the amateur scientist or even the
professional scientist what does it mean
to study this
how would they go about doing that do
they just look at the nimitz video or
the tic tac video
and they analyze it based on speed what
do they do do they speak to people do
they read your books
yeah i think i think what has to happen
is
scientists have to be collecting their
own data at this point
um we can't be relying on how do you
collect data on what's
not repeatable that's right well you do
what you do with
supernovas you watch if you can't
how do you collect data on a supernova
you have to wait till there's a
supernova and somebody happens to see it
right so
there's two possibilities really you
could you know you watch yourself so you
just
stare at the sky and collect collect
data and
review that data and watch for something
interesting that's one way to do it
um that's the chance of success is of
course small
and you would then first hope that you
would
be able to do this in a location where
you have a higher chance of success so
knowing where these things are more
frequently cited is helpful um that's
one possibility
the other possibility is to do what
does happen with supernovas is you have
amateur
astronomers spot them and then the
professionals turn all their telescopes
to look at it right so
so in that case it doesn't quite work
for ufos because
you have an amateur spot it and then the
things
zipped off and the whole event is over
but
what is becoming more and more
possible is the fact that we have more
and more satellite coverage
and more and more continuous satellite
coverage so
it is becoming more possible to take a
prominent sighting especially one that
lasts for some period of time
and to then have people go back and gets
obtain satellite images of that area to
try to get
um some imagery from the sky that would
be
you know i call that you know a
third-party eye in the sky which would
be
a great um a great asset to
you know a witness anecdotes
also there there are organizations like
new farm the
mutual ufo network that
are not exactly professional
organizations but
they they do a good job of
collecting data locally
and scientists could get could get
access to that on the on the local level
and just in in areas they know they
could
go into the field with those those teams
and
get some uh now eighty percent of those
of that data of the reports can be
explained
which is why the skeptics legitimately
say
if you can explain eighty percent of
something uh that doesn't
that that means that the other twenty
percent probably isn't worth looking at
that's not a good way of proceeding in
science because
you can usually you can you know explain
eighty percent of something
what's interesting is what what remains
i mean you know
uh so it's it's like
you know in chemistry refining something
until you get
the the important uh the important
substance
and so yes but it's it's always
interesting
it's interesting on a human level and
there are cases that are very hard to
explain
and if you can put them into a pattern
then you're beginning to
to to get valuable information in
the problem with the military data is
you know the military is driven by
what they call seek you die you know
computing control
communication and intelligence so you
have to and they keep talking about data
fusion
well even in a case like the limits
what what we have is outstanding
observation by the pirates
i mean the pilots had several minutes of
visual observation of something that was
under the plane
between the plane and the ocean that
they circled
that they observed and i you know i i
worked at one time with one of the
the pilots not the first ones but the
ones that came after them
there is no question this happened there
is no question they saw something
they had data then there was
data from the cameras that were thermal
cameras they were not people talk about
it
as if those were photographs those are
not photographs
and somewhere there is a 10-page memo
from raytheon
to the us navy saying
you know you you do what you want with
what we've given you
but remember those are not images i mean
those are thermal images
because what we've sold you is an
infrared camera
that was not designed for ufo which was
designed for something else
namely watching the exhaust of you know
of an enemy plane
so yes it's useful yes it's physical
data
but by the way we're not giving you a
distance and we're giving you a
temperature
and we're not giving you a picture now
people
are going off from that extrapolating to
all kinds of things
again we don't have the c cube die we
don't have the other
you know the control the communication
and the intelligence
we have images that are very interesting
that are captivating we have instances
of motion that we don't understand
but you know there are ways of making
things
appear that i'm not there on an
electronic screen
uh that have developed been developed as
counter measures or they're
active measures or for 40 years 50 years
so that needs to be analyzed separately
by experts so you cannot just jump to
the first
picture that somebody shows you and say
you know i got it i'm going to
convince the academy you know you have
to
get the other things but again
uh there are good amateur groups that
are
doing that in the field with
intelligence and with care and
i think you know you can join them and
go into the field with them and bring a
shovel
snooze this person named snooze wants to
know from jacques what do you plan on
doing with all the files that you've
documented
over the course of your lifetime in
investigation so
most of it i have turned over to a
university
with a 10-year embargo so i've
documented it
it covers something like 60 boxes of
stuff after filtering the junk
and it covers a lot of the work i've
done with dr heineck a lot of the
network that will be available
i think for a long time and even during
the embargo
if someone with qualifications in
science
wants to have access to it there is a
catalog and people can
will have access to to those files i
have kept
two kinds of files i've kept about 200
files that i want to continue
to study because i've been there and i
know those cases
files like this case in new mexico
i certainly keep right now for myself
and then the files of
material studies that i'm still
gathering and investigating with
with other people in silicon valley uh
who are interested and we're going to
need help by the way
and the intent is to publish and to
share the samples themselves
we're not going to put them in a you
know in a safe deposit box forever
i mean those those should be shared um
again uh dr stuart has
entrusted to me the cases from ubatuba
and some of that you know i could share
as well
i have a quick question for for jacques
though
um you mentioned scientists getting
involved and grabbing a shovel
so so let me take that a bit further if
i remember
what i read about the story of the
trinity case
um that not all of the craft was
recovered and taken away that there were
there was one point that they were
basically
bulldozing debris into an arroyo and
then filled it up
is that is that the case and if that's
the case uh exact possibility between
archaeology
you know the the recovery scene is
completely the opposite of what you see
in
mr spielberg's movies you know people
with special suits so
there's a bunch of 18 year olds who were
close to being released from the war
uh they were still in uniform they were
at uh
ground zero completely bored and they
are sent there
so the scene is they get there with a
jeep the jeep is playing the radio
so it's playing you know cowboy songs
and these kids essentially are going
under orders to gather all this
information and all that
metal that's glittering the landscape so
they are a little bit lazy and then you
know some of it that's left at the end
of the day
they're going to throw into a hole and
cover it
with dirt so presumably it's still there
the problem is that particular area is
unstable
there are creeks going through there
those arroyos are not
always psycho you know a royal seiko
sometimes it's filled with water and it
it
washes out the dirt so by now
you know 70 years later
whatever was there has been washed away
and people have been
bulldozing that area rebuilding it so
by now anything that would be at ground
level would be now
25 feet under dirt the of
the earth dam that has been rebuilt
so there is when we thought of that
and we went there with shovels there is
very little chance of
getting something back um
the um and furthermore i think that the
pieces that would be interesting
that would have structure you know other
than there are other places in new
mexico where i've gone
where we have dug up things you know we
you go with a
metal detector most of the time you're
going to find
old you know metal rusty metal
cans and i can tell you what the army
was
was what kind of uh beer they were
drinking you know in 1940
for this five or four b7 but uh
but you do find pieces of metal that
seem like they've come out of some sort
of crash
then we have those and we're going to
look at it most of the time it's
aluminum
and you know so there
you don't learn a lot by doing that but
you could be
you could be lucky and someday you could
find
you know a printed circuit or you know a
device
of some sort that doesn't mean we would
understand it
but uh you know it would be a nice thing
to analyze it
kevin do you have any other questions
for jacques
um yeah did you so so
was it padilla or the other guy had um
saved some of the s pulled something out
of the craft
and kept in his attic or something for
some time
yes there is a bracket that we that we
have
yeah that um was attached to the wall of
the craft
that was the only thing there there was
there was a paddle
that he couldn't get loose the panel was
attached to was pinned to the wall
it was about the size of your screen you
know three by two
feet it had a ring that looked like a
copper ring
and in the center there was a bracket
that turned
mr padilla who is still alive uh
got what they call the cheater bar which
is used by truckers to
you know to tighten up the the links
and he got it from the truck from the
army truck
and he branched the thing out and we
have it
they preserved it for you know all this
time
hiding it which is also one reason they
didn't come forward with the
story they thought they would be put in
jail for stealing government property
except that the the craft didn't belong
to the government
anyway we have it
and uh we don't really care where it
came from
it's interesting it's not
alien the way you'd like an alien
bracket to be
i mean in fact it has been analyzed by
three times by different labs we know
the composition it's basically aluminum
uh it's called cylimine s-i-l-u-m-i-n
it's a well-known lie of of
aluminum to give some strength to the
aluminum
there are some unusual things with it
there is no marking on it
usually there is a brand i mean usually
those are made by industry
for an industrial purpose like
activating
and it's essentially what you use in an
actuator
um you would find something like that in
a windmill
in fact i went out and bought something
like it it looks like this
okay and uh you know it turns like this
and when it turns it has you know it has
these holes here
that can activate something so uh
there are things like that that you use
in windmill
to feather the blades of the windmill in
high wind
and so on so so it's a well-known
industrial thing it's human
i have i'm in a little argument with
some of my friends
who say yes well it looks human but by
the way
it's in the metric system when you
measure the holes so
which we've done with good precision
and nobody was using the metric system
in new mexico in 1945
so where did it come from
well it could have been made for a
particular purpose
and you could say well the army made it
on the spot
or they got it from somewhere maybe from
the tower
you know it had been wrecked and they
used it to wind
an electrical wire i mean they didn't
have any power
except any power they could get from the
jeep i used to drive a jeep i know you
can generate
power useful power from the jeep and
maybe they needed a wire inside the
thing for lighting or for
cleaning or whatever that's my
hypothesis my friends are saying wait
you know we need to look inside
uh there may be some structures
inside that would tell us some more so
that's where we are i mean we have this
this ongoing argument i i think it's
human
but i can't explain the way it looks
we've gone to windmill
experts where paola went to a company
that makes
things like what i've shown you and they
say no we don't use
we have actuators in windmills but
they're not
like what you're telling us so
uh we have to look somewhere else if if
some of the people watching this have an
idea
we've i've published the dimensions and
so on in
in the book and if people have an idea
of where it would be used
maybe in aerospace maybe as actuators in
a in a big aircraft
um from 1945
uh maybe that's what it is
so we're certainly not saying it's alien
just because it's it was inside that
craft
kevin please think of any other
questions or comments you have to shock
and you're being very generous with your
time it's been
over two hours um what is meant when you
say that
it's the metric system it's made
exactly with millimeters yeah the
millimeters and
tenths of millimeters when when you
measure the
the different holes and attachments and
the size of it and so on so
it's it's very well documented in
in in our system of measurement and we
know the composition very well
the question is what was it doing there
i'll take some audience questions and
then i know both of you have to get
going
have any of you heard of operation high
jump
yes uh i don't know
i don't know much about it it it
is it the operation that had to do with
dummies
dropped from parachutes for testing
in the early days of the space program
or
testing of high atmospheric parachutes
[Music]
that was i've looked into that i have
documents about that
and that was two years later and
yes it could explain maybe some of the
material that
roswell certainly the air force has
alluded to it
to explain as well it doesn't explain
roswell
but yes there were things dropping from
the sky
in new mexico in in later years uh they
were not doing that in 1945
anywhere have you heard of bruno latour
on the sociology of sciences and the
relation between human and non-human
agencies
um that one comes from matthew nahemi
i i know the name i have not studied his
his work no
ifran nas si rick ifran nasiric says
what do you think of the new radar
footage from the navy
uh i haven't seen uh
i'm not an expert i mean the navy has
experts who
are testifying about all of this and so
on
i'm certainly not the radar expert um
the the radar tapes
on board the limits were confiscated
within hours
of the of the incident of the picture
being taken
but they were they were backups and i
understand people have access to the
backup
the in in the nimitz incident
all the radars were advanced radars on
the princeton
the princeton was the electronic ship
the the the the nimitz was the aircraft
carrier
so the interesting radar data would come
from the princeton
and i don't know where it went uh again
some of those in in some of the cases
where i was told the air force had
classified project bluebook data
it was because of the radar it wasn't
because of the ufo
in if somebody reports a light in the
sky
and there is a radar reading of it
from a classified radar the case will be
classified
that doesn't mean that the light is
interesting so again
you you learn to work with the military
they have their own way of thinking
about things
and if you if you have a classified
radar
and it uh it paints something strange
you're not going to have access to
something strange
even though it may or may not be
interesting because the radar is
classified
diggy's journal wants to know if you
have any thoughts as to why the aliens
supposedly refer to us as containers or
vessels
um have you heard that before
no no i've no i'm trying to go from
the data we've got that we can find and
they can take to the lab again i mean to
convince the scientific community
we have to be able to document where it
was
and then to share it with other labs i
mean that's what you do
when with this trinity case the
actual craft when it was being described
did it look like if it was
all one piece the reason i asked this is
that
bob lazar said when he was working on
kraft that it looked like
as if it was made with wax and then
slightly melted down so there were no
hard edges it was only
curvy but all as if it's one lego block
i i will not comment on
any statement by mr lazar
because there are too many things we
just don't know about
uh the conditions where
this may have happened and even who is
he really is so uh again
this case is exceptional because we have
the witnesses
we have actually we have a false witness
that we haven't talked about who came
later
and could describe sort of nail all of
the preceding things together
and she's still alive very you know very
smart
woman who has given us a lot of
descriptions
of the the samples that we can relate
back
the of course we've asked mr padilla
and you know about the conditions of the
craft itself
it didn't seem to be one one piece
it seemed to have panels but there was
no nail there were no rivets there were
no
we don't know how those panels were held
together obviously it was
extraordinarily strong
because it dug a road
when it fell after hitting the tower
one of presumably one of those panels
was ejected
and then this thing grounded itself
and then back a path all the way down
the hill
under power i mean an airplane would
have blown into pieces at that point
okay it it and the this was described as
you would need a bulldozer with a
hundred foot blade
you know and probably a couple of hours
to dig that
road down the in fact that's a road that
the army used
in part to drive their truck
and you know i've been there i mean this
is a gouge in the earth you know that
district
so this thing was heavy it was in a
neighborhood of anywhere from 5 to 10
tons
it wasn't 100 tons but it wasn't
500 kilograms i mean it was it was heavy
it was under power and it was able to
keep its
uh you know integrity as it was
plowing that path down the hill and the
bushes were
catching fire everything else i mean
that's
you know we we know it was a very
violent scene
and at the end of it it was it kept its
integrity
to the point where the air force could
or the army could take it
with a crane and put it sideways
when they put it sideways the kids had a
chance to see the underside
and remember the people who were inside
said it was 12 to 13 feet
inside from a flat floor
well the thing was 15 feet approximately
high
so there was two or three feet under the
floor
so there was an engine if there is a
concept of an engine
that's the only place where it could
have been the rest of it was empty
there was no opening on the underside
there were sort of
bumps or structures that were not
damaged by the way
i mean the thing that didn't have a
landing gear or anything else
i mean so it was strong enough that it
could plow its path through the
landscape
without breaking up inside it was
sort of buffed and you know but
it was it had its integrity as
as a piece of metal so
if you want to think about propulsion
you know anti-gravity anything you want
this was certainly not you know
propelled by any kind of rocket
or any kind of thing that could have had
an exhaust
it had no exhaust ability
so that's again that's an important
point
the again when we know approximately the
volume
where there would have been space for a
propulsion system
okay where can people find your book
it's on amazon you know my name uh
trinity uh the
it's called trinity the best kept secret
it's available in paperback and uh
in as an ibook or as an ebook on
kindle great great and kevin
what's next for you and where can people
find out more about you as well
um i'm still working with uapx and we're
hoping to
continue working to try to get um
imagery of uaps and
to understand better what they are um
where can people find out about me
my website's probably the best place
um knuthlab.org
so my last name lab.org that's it
thank you very much for inviting me um
thank you so much man thank you
i always learned a lot from the
questions and
again uh this is not something that one
person is going to solve
is going to take you know a team
of people with different ideas and
different skills okay thank you so much
both of you i appreciate
how generous you've been with your time
and jock and kevin i'm sure i'll be
speaking to you again at some point
perhaps when you have something else to
promote or there's the disclosure
i have to define it first
thank you so much for having me it's
been a great pleasure to spend this
thank you
thank you thanks bye thank you
bye bye bye
for those people who are still watching
there is a video with kevin knuth
and i on the channel which is one of the
most popular videos on the channel
please check that out
if you want to see more conversations
like this please do consider going to
patreon.com kurtjmungle i
am not this is not a ufo channel
and so i was a bit concerned with the
huge influx of ufo
subscribe people who are interested in
the ufo phenomenon
who subscribed recently but as i was
talking to a few
i mentioned that what my primary
interest is in is theoretical physics
and consciousness as well as free will
and god
and to me this idea of ufos and aliens
and so on
seem to be related somehow so i'm trying
to fit it into the puzzle and
investigate it
as rigorously as i can my background's
in physics and math
and unlike my either way as i was
talking to some of the people who
recently subscribed and i was telling
them about my disconcerting thoughts
feeling like they're going to be
disappointed by the channel's emphasis
on psychology philosophy
physics math and consciousness
i was told that those who are interested
in ufos tend to be
open-minded or open people in general
and
i'm hoping that is the case because this
channel doesn't focus on ufos
though i talk about it frequently just
wanted to clear that up
i'm going to be going through some of
the comments now thank you all for
watching i appreciate it so much
tim wilson wants to know if anyone will
chat with mick west
i don't mind chatting with mick west but
i'm a neophyte when it comes to this
ufo topic which means that
i don't know much i'm pretty much an
amateur getting into this i was
criticized
of that when i was speaking to jeremy
corbell because i was asking somewhat
jejune questions but to me the point
is one that i'm interested in this topic
and who better to talk to than
someone who or people who are experts in
it i get the critique that i'm wasting
some of these extremely intelligent and
informed people's time
with my depthless questions
at least with the jeremy corbell video
in that case not with the kevin knuth
video
and that's a a valid critique the other
way to view it
is that there's an advantage into being
new and seeing from a fresh perspective
and asking questions
here's an example there's this
mathematician his name is terry tal one
of the best in the world
and yet he gives talks to elementary
schools
okay what question can an elementary
school
child ask terry tao that's going to
inform
terry towel well let's not talk about
elementary school let's talk about
a first-year concept called compactness
that seems extremely elementary there's
something called a compact set
in mathematics but terry tau you ask him
what's a compact set he actually has
a three-page pdf which gives insight
into compactification and that's an
elementary question so i don't
particularly mind asking
cosmetic or vacuous questions although i
try not to
i don't particularly mind with regard to
this ufo topic just because
while i'm cosmetic and vacuous and i'm
dipping my toes into it
please consider talking to travis walton
i will consider it
a special thank you to kevin knuth
because
he about 15 minutes before recording
or 30 minutes before he came on he said
kurt there's a huge problem i'm
presenting tomorrow and there's some
issue with the slides and i have to work
on this now
and i said i basically
unfairly forced him i said come on man
please come to this just join don't
worry
if you're thinking about some other
topic while you're here just be here
anyway
because the this was announced that it's
jacques vallee
jacques vale sorry and kevin knew so he
came and if he seemed or appeared
distracted it's because it's my fault
have a great day everyone
you